hey guys what is up I'm cat Tim I'm
filling in for Greg cuz he took this
week off to get plastic surgery um the
pictures look great
though
so it's December 28th which is a big
deal I know Gypsy Rose Blanchard is out
of prison today Gypsy of course was that
Missouri child abuse victim who served
seven years for her role in her mother's
mother's murder uh which means it's
probably only going to be like a month
before she's on Joe
Rogan after that maybe Dancing with the
Stars I don't know but it also means
December 28th that a lot of you guys who
are maybe off for Christmas are going to
have to go back to work soon which is a
bummer even if you're retired and you're
never working and you're just enjoying
your life cuz like you have balance of
nature giving you the energy to play
with your grandkids and then you have
relaxium to give you that little hit at
night to go to sleep even if that's you
then it can still be a bummer when
Christmas is over because if Christmas
is the most wonderful time of the year
the way everybody says that it is then
that means that after Christmas it's all
just downhill to less wonderful times no
offense to the Lexus December to
remember
event when Christmas ends a lot of
things will be different for example a
lot of those ladies that you know broke
up with their Wall Street power broker
boyfriends for dudes who work at
bakeries in their Hometown they might
start to regret it after the first time
they have to fly
Spirit Christmas being over also might
mean that a lot of you might have a
harder time finding an old man with a
beard to let you sit on his lap notice I
said you and not me cuz I can find that
whenever I
want am I bragging too
much also a lot of you guys are going to
have to wait till next year for Elf on a
Shelf but I have an elf who watches me
all year round except he hides himself
around my home
I know it's what happens when men don't
watch sports or have
hobbies still a lot of the christmy
stuff doesn't last forever even for me
and I don't think that that's all bad
like if I ate all the time the way I eat
on Christmas I would have too much acid
reflux to hold down a job and if we all
drank the way we drink on Christmas all
of us would probably be alcoholics if we
all spent money the way we do at
Christmas we'd be broke but that doesn't
mean we can't keep anything we do on
Christmas going all year just one
example would be letting go in a good
way like not when Bill deasio murdered
that groundhog um let me explain so
Christmas usually means that you get to
spend more time with your family than
you usually do for me it's my favorite
part about the whole thing my family
lives in another part of the country and
I don't get to spend as much time with
them as I would like to so when I do get
the chance like I do on Christmas I try
to make the most of it and a lot of
times that that can mean putting
differences aside right if you feel a
fight that's starting to brew on
Christmas or maybe one actually breaks
out you tend to just stop you know you
can agree to disagree or you can do my
favorite thing which is just pretend it
wasn't happening and ask someone who was
just screaming at someone else if they
can pass the potatoes please because you
don't want it to ruin that special time
right especially cuz we all have that
one relative who's been like ripping so
many sigs for so long that we don't know
how they're still alive let alone that
they'll be alive the next time and you
don't want to have wasted all that time
preparing with the decorations and the
presents and the food just to run
upstairs and cry especially when you're
finally old enough to stop getting sent
to your room which I hope happens for me
before meno
pause Christmas time is special but a
lot of the reason for that is because we
treat it like it's special if you don't
want to do that for your family maybe
try to do it for yourself
a recent CBS News poll found that people
who think that their family life is
going well are a lot more likely to say
that they're more happy in general and
it's probably going to be more important
next year than it ever has been CU
there's that whole election thing coming
up next year a University of Minnesota
Professor he said America is quote
sitting on a powder keg and the fuse has
been lit which gives kegs a Bad
Name the bottom line we each have the
power to decide who we want to vote for
hopefully but no single one of us has
the power to decide which way it goes
unless you're a psycho like John wils
Booth but if you're not the only thing
we have the power to do is to decide how
we will handle it we can decide if we
want to let political stuff ruin our
relationships or we can decide to do it
the old fashion way with infidelity and
drugs or we can take the attitude that
all our time together on Earth is
special and it's not less worthy of
valuing just cuz it's not Christmas and
sure not every day can be a holiday no
matter what your uncle tries to tell you
when he's trying to get you to do shots
with him before your nephew's Christmas
concert but we can make it all a little
easier on each other and even a little
more fun especially if you just got out
of
prison let's welcome tonight's guests we
went on a Safari and we were still the
wildest animals host of Kennedy Saves
the World podcast
Kennedy he looks like your sixth grade
biology teacher Fox News contributor
Charlie
hurt he's our favorite guest tonight
based on alphabetical order comedian
Adam
Hunter and when he gets on stage the
ladies Can't Behave comedian Joe Mackie
okay Mackie this might sound kind of
weird so guys hope you kind of know what
I mean here when I was doing the
monologue I realized during it that like
you have a
family
which like I I guess I always
technically knew was true but it's kind
of weird to think about like I know you
didn't just like spring out of the
ground but uh anyway uh how was your
Christmas with did you were were you
with your family I was with my family
and it was glorious cat because I try to
remember like you s the monologue just
appreciate the things that make you
happy like your family dogs eating a
whole vegetable lasagna seeing
Attractive people
trip but here's the thing cat you know
uh you can't let politics ruin
everything you know like politics has
ruined Halloween don't wear a sombrero
politics has ruined Christmas you know
all gifts cause climate change uh the
food pyramid gave us diabetes and that
put the keyos on Easter candy you know
just don't let
politics Bo it's delay laugh
today but you know politics just ruins
everything uh I mean beer beer stay out
of contentious issues beer you know
people who are drunk don't need reasons
to fight you know I have enough problems
you know with drunk people when they
want to fight me because they see that
their girlfriends are hitting on
me Kennedy I love you your family a lot
how was your Christmas uh it was great
uh you actually have a way of getting
the best information out of my teenage
daughters and everyone needs a friend
like cat because everyone knows that
moms are the least cool people on the
planet so to have a friend who is able
to speak their language and subversively
get in there and pull everything out of
them but what they don't realize is that
cat is the worst confident on in the
world and she tells me everything oh I
mean like I I'm not going to go to jail
I'm not going to withhold information
about a minor from her mother I don't is
that a crime I don't know no but I I do
feel like I'm I'm going to hear a story
from one of you either you or my older
daughter that you will have visited her
for the weekend in college and I'm not
sure that you'll both stay out of prison
that
weekend that's true that's absolutely
true Charlie how was your Christmas
would you have any predictions for next
year do you think we're all going to
kill each other or do you think it's
going to be okay no I think those the
only two options no I think we'll work
it all out we generally do we've had uh
we've had harder times no but it is true
I mean you know family uh you know and
and I think that the whole reason that
politics you know gets acrimonious is
that when people turn to politics and
think that they're going to get out of
politics what they should turn to their
family for and if you think that
politics is going to answer all your
problems or solve all your problems
you're going to be really disappointed
and then you're also going to be really
pissed off at your family family
probably yeah that's the weird thing
when people will be in the you know on
social media in the comments defending
some politician who I guarantee does not
give a that that person exists it's like
go talk to your kids you know what do
you think I I agree with everything you
guys are saying I I know that I spent
holidays with my family and uh my
daughter is five and we're very close
and uh the other day she's like Daddy I
want to marry you and I'm like honey you
can't marry me and then she's like why
my wife's like you'll be
disappointed
but uh I remember when I when I got my
wife pregnant uh we were not married at
the time I don't know how to tell
Scandal well I didn't how to tell her
parents so I got him a gift uh for
Christmas that wasn't really wrapped and
they're like you're not really good at
rapping things I'm like we speaking of
it
[Applause]
um
but but my wife and I we do argue like
the other day she's like you never do
what I want to do and I'm like all right
tomorrow night will stay home complain
about me
um and like even even even like like
today I was like let's bu hide and go
seek you guys hide and then I came here
yeah um no Kennedy speaking of marriage
my husband was giving me a little bit of
an attitude about having to drive all of
us back in the rain for my
cat he was like I'm not going to die on
the New Jersey to pick because of a cat
which I get where he's coming from but
also like I think what I'll do next year
is because he even suggested that I'm
going to insist on getting a car service
to go back with the cat
alone well I mean have you ever seen
Tunes the driving cat on Saturday Night
Live Well decades ago when Saturday
Night Live was funny there was a very
special animated short about a cat who
drove but it always ended horribly so I
I think the threat has to be that Chens
will drive next year if we did yeah and
by the way cam is complaining about
driving on the New Jersey turn bike you
guys drove through Detroit I know I mean
in the winter and but if we did all die
in the car crash by the way way chin
would somehow
live he would but also cardiologist
would be like chin I'm very glad you
made it through absolutely no but do you
have a dog we have a dog bring the dog
oh the dog's also there some people when
I talked about this on the last episode
on Twitter got the impression that I
made cam Drive alone with the cat to
Detroit by himself and they were calling
me all these names I laugh so hard
thinking about him just driving alone
with a cat all the way to Detroit okay
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else